[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy with the
chucky cheesiest puns on the internet
and this video are breaking down
willie's wonderland the movie stars
nicholas cage
aka mystery
in what is one of his weirdest roles yet
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking the entire movie down
it's ending and who cage might actually
be
heavy spoilers ahead and if you enjoy
the video then please click the thumbs
up button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into willie's
wonderland
okay so willy's wonderland is basically
five nights at freddy's which we can't
say for legal reasons
and the film centers around a haunted
chucky cheeses
which we also can't say for legal
reasons the backstory of the location is
a weird one
and we discover throughout the film that
the restaurant was originally owned by a
serial killer called jerry willis
not too focused on his trip advisor
reviews willis used the location to live
out his twisted fantasies
and over time he recruited several sick
individuals
these guys would make a restaurant that
gordon ramsay renovates look like the
ritz
and they primarily used to place inside
willie's called the super happy fun room
as their hunting ground in here they
throw birthday parties which would end
with the killers brutally murdering the
family there
while stressed as the cute and cuddly
animals i mean it's not as bad as my
birthday in 2020
but still not nice eventually this drew
the attention of the police
and they raided the place one night only
to discover that willis and his buddies
had carried out a suicide pact
turns out there was actually a satanic
edge to this and their souls had been
transferred into the bodies of the
animatronics
because if you could shift your soul
into a machine why wouldn't you move it
into a giant animal instead of scarlett
johansson's vibrati
vibranium gloves or whatever anyway 10
years passed and the restaurant was
bought by american stereotype
tex mcadoon tex wanted to renovate the
lot and bulldoze the area
but the contractor who is scheduled to
carry out the job was killed the day
before
and more strange things started to
happen in the town there were a number
of murders
and it slowly became clear that the
vengeful serial killers had returned
tex and the local sheriff decided to
strike up a deal with the devil
and they went to willis offering a
bargain in exchange for not attacking
the townsfolk
they would supply unwitting victims to
willie but there's one person
that they didn't count on nicholas cage
their pinball
wizard anyway the movie opens with a
woman who looks like heidi from married
at first sight australia
being murdered and it's not too long
before we're introduced to a young live
her parents were lured to the restaurant
and they were killed in front of her
eyes
local sheriff eloise took the girl for
herself and since then she and her
friends have been trying to put an end
to willy and his schemes
now liv pretty much becomes the
character that does all the talking
because nicholas cages aka the janitor
is playing this strong and silent type
i'm not even joking the guy doesn't have
one line of dialogue in the entire film
and therefore liv becomes the most
relatable person as she wants to burn
down willie's and all that it represents
now early on in the movie the janitor
rolls into town and is taken out by a
tyre trap
and thus he falls into the sacrifice
game set up by the townsfolk
the janitor is told by tex and a
mechanic named jed that they will fix up
his car
if he cleans willie's up throughout the
night he's haunted by the animatronics
of the location
and asked to fight them off one by one
all whilst continuing the job
it's completely ridiculous and at times
i was asking myself
whether it was intentionally bad or just
actually bad
and therefore even worse because it was
trying to be bad
i'm still a bit torn on the movie and
now it has a lot of fun moments
there's also a lot of parts that don't
really land
now one thing i write about cage's
character is that he's completely
unfazed by the entire ordeal and every
time he tackles an animatronic monster
he tapes himself up puts on a new
t-shirt and goes back to cleaning
slowly living his paths crosses the cast
of willy's murder her friends
and it leads to eloise trying to offer
the janitor up to willy herself
willie rips her in half and this leads
to him facing off against the janitor
in a climactic battle the next morning
tex and jed arrive to see the damage
and they're shocked to find that he's
lasted the night and has destroyed all
of the animatronics inside
at the restaurant tex in jedd discuss
actually opening it back
up but their celebrations are cut short
by siren zara
who lights the gasoline from the prior
knight this destroys all three in the
explosion but the restaurant does
survive
perhaps hinting at a sequel down the
line left with her family dead and
nowhere to go
live in the janitor ride off into the
sunset killing tito the turtle on the
way out
ending the movie and also freeing the
townsfolk who have been victim to the
curse of willies
so what this was going on and what's up
with the janitor
well i actually believe that cage is
either playing a personification of
death or the devil
throughout the film the character seems
completely unfazed by everything that's
going on
and even when he has a gun pointed to
his head by the sheriff
he doesn't seem to care he even waves at
her at one point after this
and goes back to cleaning showing he
just wants to keep up his end of the
deal with text
now deals in general are mentioned
throughout the movie and as we know
willian co made one with satan himself
instead of surrendering
it is possible that because of the
janitor's adherence to deals
that he's come to collect on the one
with willy and this is where he was
driving to at the start of the film
on the way his tires were flattened and
thus he had to strike up his own deal
with jedd and tex
which stopped him from just going to the
location and killing everyone there
this deal clearly has a lot of bearing
over his actions in the movie
and tex even says it's important to take
plenty of breaks and to also wear the
t-shirt
both of which he does without any real
agency himself
to the point that when his watch goes
off and alerts him to a break
he drops what he's doing and then goes
and plays some pinball
cages character also loves games and
typically in fiction
death has been personified as being
someone that has fun playing them too
he drinks punch energy drink and has so
many weird little characteristics
that he's just fascinating to watch i
did try and enhance the dog tags that
are present in his car at the start
but they aren't clear enough to see so
his name does still remain a mystery
however at the end of the movie even
though he's completely unconnected from
the explosion involving texan jed
his sunglasses light with flames almost
like he's seeing it himself
he has no history no real future and
there's a lot of mystery surrounding him
that i think is definitely open to
interpretation
to me he is either the devil of death
but i can see people disagreeing
he may just be someone with a mental
compulsion that means he can't break his
routine
as he even stops fighting at one point
to go back to his habits
cage himself has said he doesn't want to
clear anything up as he wants a mystery
to remain around the character
however he does know the answer and
hopefully we get it one day because it's
killing me
now as for the movie itself i kind of
have mixed feelings on it
i know it's supposed to just be a stupid
schlock movie so it kind of feels bad to
ding it for that
i just wish there was a bit more meat to
the film and it runs a bit thin
on plot by the midpoint once he's beaten
up the first three killers it kind of
falls into a routine
i feel like they could have focused a
lot more on the origin story of willy's
wonderland
that was by far the best part of the
movie i think and i would have loved to
have seen a lot more of that
rather than just picking up after the
fact and then paying some lip service to
it
the janitor i'm a bit unsure of two
because i know so little about him
without cage i think that he'd be a
pretty uninteresting character
due to him being a blank slate and
though the actor brings a lot of star
power and charisma
i'm not sure that the character works on
his own i also felt a bit like the
quote-unquote kid characters were a bit
cliche
and didn't really care about them to
begin with so when they died
i felt like we were just going through
the motions that being said though
you probably already know whether you're
the kind of person that's gonna like
this movie or not
based on whether you like the concept
and cage as an actor
i personally thought it was okay but i
think the idea could be pulled off
better in either a sequel
prequel or even the five nights at
freddy's film
it's difficult to really give this
either a glowing review
or a terrible one as it's probably meant
to be stupid
therefore my score is gonna be 5 out of
10
but i can see people disagreeing with
that on both ends of the spectrum
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie so make sure you
comment below and let me know
don't forget that on the 28th of
february we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 mcu 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of one division which will be
linked on screen right now
we've gone over the last episode from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
is